five seconds of summer Calum hood let's
go Luke Hemmings a Chanel 5 5 seconds of
summer
Michael cliff I always kill thanks for
sitting most handsome one let's go all
right we'll start with this one I like
this stuff I got it in Japan from a
place on cat Street Shibuya it's the
craziest hair gel ever and it's used by
the dudes in our Youngblood video the
rockabilly culture is prominent in Japan
and those guys are featured in the
Youngblood video anyone seen how I play
the drums I play like a beast this is
the only stuff that will hold my hair up
for a whole other show it is from a
brand called cream soda
and you can only get it in this one
place and they don't even ship outside
Japan so I need to tour Japan often to
make sure I get some of this stuff
carrying on this next one is called
sunshine in a bottle this stuff makes me
confident I feel really positive with it
on hence the name sunshine it smells
like literal sunshine it's like very
citrusy it reminds me at home we had a
big old lemon tree and for the fans
watching I have a lemon tree account
apply this to the neck fam fam one on
the stomach which is weird I know why I
do that
and then one on my left hand never the
right don't know what the way I smell
should match my personality and sunshine
is perfect for that
this next one
same place where my hair gel comes from
Joni Pandora is the lead role in our
video for Youngblood his to do with a
really tall hair and he gave me this
with a mix tape of his and his band in
Japan but I use this every single day to
comb my hair I actually have three of
these white one black one in this orange
one isn't my favorite one and I travel
with this one as you can see it's
covered in red hair done but this is a
major cave for me I wear Park adolfs a
lot I'm very inspired by artist Yayoi
Kazuma and Buddy Guy to people that wear
polka dots a lot one person draws them
the other wears them I have photos
prepared this is Buddy Guy very
influential rock and roll blues
guitarist on all probably of most
people's favorite guitarists he was the
influence for them it says something
about it that's positive and expressive
for an artist to wear and I try wear
them every day
I have like 10 different polka dot shirt
as you can see I wear them under this
black suit the black suit is for the
battered and broken who we make music
for and I got that from Johnny Cash so
there's a lot of old influence and I
wear polka dots as much as possible on
to the next fellow so
I don't even mean to bring this in
that's how much of an essential this is
it was just in my backpack
you see Exhibit A also Exhibit B here at
about 60 of these you can wear this at
any type of vet school formal or prom if
you're going to bed if you're working
out
$10 Haynes sells them at Target if you
want to nip on down there and this is
this kind of the ultimate the ultimat
rope the Calvin Klein one gold travel
size how I discovered this it was early
in the morning at Ashton Irwin's house I
went into the bathroom and I saw this
and I put it on because I thought I
smelled terrible I was dancing all night
sick and I came out and this lady goes
oh you smoke great and that really
struck me because no one's ever
commented on my musk before so I went
home on Amazon and I bought this with a
sex phone that never came and also some
Nespresso pods that never came but this
came and now this is my my scent here
[Music]
your left wrist and unlike Ashton I also
go right wrist
this is a sunscreen facial mist with
zinc in it because after years of
touring if you look up me in 2014 he
looks far better and happier than 2019
me but this helps with that it's it's
got sunscreen in it so your skin doesn't
get weathered from the Sun and also zinc
because I had to know what zinc does I
don't even know what it is I think it's
a metal and as SPF 25 which is pretty
pretty good I think it's one of the
highest right it's the fourth highest
protect your face everybody last one is
kind of a Russian doll here it's my
wallet but also inside the wallet I have
two things I'm photo of me and my mother
joy her name is and I also have a ticket
to one of the greats
Wolfmother long live Australian rock and
roll I don't know which one I treasure
more because Wolfmother did tend to rock
that night at a particularly good nut
mom's pretty cool I guess
this was taken in 2017 for two years
I've kept it in my wallet take it out
5:55 a.m. every morning I'm going alone
yeah that's my two last ones that I keep
[Music]
alright that was a fantastic throw these
are called vocal zones I don't know who
introduced me to these actually have
sugar in them I didn't realize this is
why I can't get into shape damn it
then know that anyway these are for
singing I use these every day and now
I'm regretting it because I've never at
the back of these things but their vocal
zones therefore I'm a singer so
hopefully they make me sound good I use
them today for every show I do this
usually have one of my amp so I can use
it whenever I want
it's an essential use it every day the
second one is my phone my phone and call
loved ones texts loved ones I've got
photos and videos of my dog actually my
background got me and my dog and then
girl so I'm doing it disturbed because I
respect the process it's good when you
wake up specially on the tool bus you
got a map straight away before anything
check the blue dot see what city or
country you're in and guide problems
also it's got my neurotically writing
down in my notes you can see and then
you can record voice memos I recorded
one today actually it's pretty bad don't
hear this
[Music]
so that's for the next hit from five
sauce and you heard it here first my PSP
I usually try and take some sort of
gaming device wherever I go because I
can't really stop thinking and this
helps but this one is like the original
PSP I don't know if anyone had this or
remembers this look at the game discs
they're huge
I found this on my last trip to
Australia we were there and I was in my
childhood bedroom I noticed that I had
my favorite game ever on this still and
no one else makes this Tony Hawk and as
the project date the last good one sorry
Tony
my last save game was in 2006 and then
his like 2006 nothing and then 2019 from
like yesterday like a Ridge Racer Star
Wars Battlefront 2 fantastic game okay
boots I've got a lot of boots but these
at the moment my favorite because
they're black but also they have like
stalls and stuff on them so they're kind
of a little bit casual I mean for me
they're a little bit casual but then
they have like some extra stuff I love
wearing boots it's kind of part of who I
am now for stage especially these are
actually a women's brand called mother
advice but I had them specially make
them because my feet are big obviously
bigger than the average woman that was
still too small so I took them back and
they made them even bigger I think they
put like a bunch of stuff in it to
spread out the top because I got fat
feet here's my boots and they're
essential
you need me to throw these or anything
did I do it all right
these I'm Magic the Gathering cards I
think it's important to have like a
thing that you do on tour and what I do
on toy I don't I don't play Magic the
Gathering I try and convince other
people to play and no one will play with
me because I don't have any no deference
I tried to convince Callum to play and
he was so close oh my god he was so
close he was there and they were like um
chicken tenders for and he was like nope
I'm done
best caught in the day I'll show you
that's caught in the deck is this one
nickel bolus the Nick nickel the bolus
so I did have some dealt idea how to
pronounce it but he's a good con nickel
bolus okay I know what this looks like
I get it go like wow that guy has a
Heineken caught a silver Heineken Cod he
must be a loyalty member no let me tell
you the story I met a person I catch
hella and this is really bad that I
don't remember who it was she literally
handed me like a box I say oh cool
and so I open up the box and it is a
silver Heineken cod and I was like oh
what is this card with him with an email
on the back she goes free Heineken for
life not only that but you get free of
all of the other brands that Heineken
own can you even believe that I forgot I
had it until today you like what's your
essentials and I'm like oh my god this
is so essential to me kind of my next
one is
thumbstick now I know everyone's like
well what's he going on the thumbstick
people will never know I'll never tell
you what's on this stump stick except
for right now I'm gonna tell you what's
on it
music games I actually have hey Kalin
you remember David suit you remember how
he had a vote
of Halo the first Halo I got that on hit
you could plug this in and play the
first Halo and it looks like crap but
hold on I'm not even at the best part
yet if you're like oh usb3 how did I I
bought the new 2018 MacBook like that
BAM USB see at all times i DJ office
parties office holiday parties
specifically I got to keep it with me my
lost essential is my hat
let me just before we do this let me
check that my hair's yep looks
absolutely dreadful as usual it's a look
oh and it's got my initials on the side
which Catherine had one made for every
city that we went to in the last war and
this one was yell a Dodgers one and I
kept it and I think I have about three
of these if you're a fan of our band
you'll probably see me wearing this hat
in probably 90% of our photos and it's
because I'm so compulsive that I refuse
to cut my hair but I hate my hair at the
same time there's no winning so in the
morning hat on
good to go and I always look
underdressed for everything so it really
helps well that's it that's been our
essentials and the things that we keep
with us I hope you found it interesting
I hope that you enjoyed a little insight
into us as people Thank You GQ for
having us
I'll see you later
[Music]